amazing news to announce for our co-host
here no surprise a CBS Saturday morning
exclusive Michelle in just two months
will release her first book ever and we
have the cover reveal belonging A
daughter's search for identity through
loss and love comes out on March 14th
from harpercollins it's the remarkable
story of Michelle's incredibly fractured
childhood the search for answers in the
five decades since her birth Michelle
tell us more we've been hearing about
this for a while we're very excited for
you I am excited I'm so nervous you know
we're so used to delving into other
people's lives this is truly a humbling
experience for me because it's about me
my belonging and me sort of coming out
of this insecurity Jeff is looking at me
and saying
many people who know you have have heard
this story but it's not it's good that
more people are getting a chance right
right and so sort of was birthed out of
this story that I did for CBS mornings
where I was told to kind of go and talk
about my 25 years of covering social
justice and a 20-second turn that I made
talking about the family turned into
someone calling me and saying you have a
book can't wait to read it so it is
coming out and pre-order it's where most
you buy any of your books so I got a PDF
I'm going to start reading it today
exactly